Hello, everybody. This is Dr. Kevin Conner's again episode six of my journey through cancer.
Today I'm going to be talking about the Budwig protocol and the Budwig diet.
That's not something I've been doing very long at all. In fact, in full disclosure, I just started it just this weekend.
So something familiar with a lot. Nothing we really ever pushed in our practice. We have
numerous dozens of dozens of patients that were already doing it. And I found no problem in continuing doing it.
I never asked anybody to stop doing it. But I haven't had personal experience with it.
I thought I better get my feet wet in this. So I started that this weekend. And it tastes delicious,
especially since I've been off dairy for over a year now. There is dairy in the Budwig protocol.
The first thing that everybody asks me is that if I'm not supposed to be eating dairy,
should I be doing the Budwig protocol because you are doing cottage cheese with the Budwig protocol?
And my answer is yes, I believe you can because when you are using your immersion blender with the cottage cheese
and the the flaxseed oil, you are emulsifying the fat in there. Now you're still getting IGF 1 in the dairy.
So if you test it out with IGF 1, personally ask me about this because I may not have told you that.
When we test people, we test if they react to IGF 1. Those are people that we highly recommend
the fasting mimicking diet too. That maybe Budwig protocol isn't something you want to do.
So if you're a patient of mindfulness to this, if you're not doing the Budwig protocol that I would
suggest maybe you stay continuing to not do the public Budwig protocol. If you are doing it,
I've already given you the AOK on it then you could continue to do it. Now you are using cottage cheese,
you're using good cold press flaxseed oil, little bit about Joanna Budwig. She was a brilliant researcher
of fats, saturated fats, hydrogenated fats. She was the first person she lived was born and raised
and lived in Germany and she was the first person to raise the red flag against trans fats causing
cancer and disease. She was a researcher so you don't hear a lot about her. Her information was
taken and used by other institutions but she was quite a brilliant person. She believed that she
found a major piece of the cure for cancer by proper use of fats so that the cells could get the fat
that they needed and will help oxygenate the cells and she believed this protocol was very beneficial.
It's just another protocol. I think it's a piece of your big protocol and that's how I've always
looked at it. Now what it's using is cottage cheese and flaxseed oil and flaxseeds. So you end up
not going to describe it. I'm going to point you with the next slide to a video that could describe it
literally. It's so simple. You use two parts cottage cheese to one part flaxseed and then for every
part of flaxseed oil I mean for every part of flaxseed oil you're using grown flaxseeds and you have
to grind them fresh. So you're going to need a few pieces of equipment for this. You're going to
need a coffee grinder and you're going to need an immersion blender. So a coffee grinder and an
immersion blender. When you take the flaxseed oil and you mix it with double the content of cottage
cheese and you use it immersion blender it's going to look like this. It's actually going to look
broader than this. I stole this picture off the internet. I should have taken a picture of my product
this weekend so if you haven't done it so you don't want to look like this. This is cottage cheese
maybe blended up but you have to add the flaxseed oil so it'll look a little tannish golden
look to it and then you grind the flaxseeds and you add the flaxseeds to this and then you mix it
up together and you are allowed to put some fruit. I use some raspberries. It tastes like maybe cottage
cheese pudding. So I used to love cottage cheese but I think part of it was I liked the texture of cottage
cheese. Well you lose the texture because you're blending it up with the immersion blender and I suppose
you might not like the taste. Some people don't like the taste of this. That's why they add the fruit
because of the flaxseed oil. Now I don't buy the taste but of course with my nasal polyps I can taste
anything so I think it tastes great. So that's going to have to be something that you're going to have
to experiment with. A video that I would highly recommend is this YouTube video right here. This is a
gal who heard her husband had a little baby who had cancer and they've been dealing with this little
baby with cancer. Their website is www.sternstren method.com. I think that's what it is. You'll find it
on her YouTube video. This is just a six minute video. She does a great job. You'll see the little baby
little guy comes up here to eat the budwig mixture afterwards. It just loves it. This is an
immersion blender. This is a coffee grinder. You're using flaxseed oil and cottage cheese and fresh
flax seeds. You have to blend them and grind them right there because ground up flax seeds really
go rancid quite quickly. So you have to have whole flax seeds. You grind them and you mix it together
literally. It takes two minutes to do this protocol and these are super easy to clean and this is
easy to clean. So it's really a simple thing to add. It's a simple thing to do and it could have
great benefits. So go to this YouTube channel right here. I'm not going to try it. I thought, well,
maybe I'll make my own video but what? We'll just give them credit. These are great people. They use
a ripe bishie. They use a whole bunch of different things for their little guy and he's had great
results. So great testibodies there too. So all right, hopefully that helps. Thanks so much.